I love me some...
Barnyard ASMR, baby.
Ooh!
Hi!
Everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello!
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hi.
Welcome.
Back to the Walking Dead part.
Four.
Three.
I'm getting a little ahead of myself.
Yeah, I had to look at my stream then.
Yes.
this is a good episode is it I'm excited I'm excited um I've been really enjoying this so far so I can't wait we're not gonna cause mischief I was gonna say I can't wait to cause mischief but no we are a good example to little miss Clementine but guys before I before I play the game oh my gosh I almost played more water park simulator today I was like I was like what if I just played a little more I think I'm addicted to that game I think I have a problem is the walking dead what they call it when you go out to touch grass no I'm not walking these these boots are made for walking and And that's just what they'll do.
One of these days, these boots are gonna walk all over you.
Have fun.
Welcome to my book, chef.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm excited.
This has been fun so far.
Yeah!
Mito, it's already my...
Oh, it's already the fourth here.
I thought it said your fourth birthday.
Watching this while making Wisp charms to bring Safer of Expo.
Zubu!
Happy birthday!
Happy happy birthday About my gamer subs merch And wore the shirt to work The back was covered Okay good
Rodrigo thank you She's addicted to the grind I don't know there was something about it Maybe like it was like a trauma bonding event Or something I don't know how to explain it I don't know I just really liked it I also can't stop playing the water park game Why did you do this to me?
Oh, so invisible boost.
Thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
Surely it wasn't the swimsuits.
I mean.
No, I don't know.
It was something about the rush and just running around and mopping stuff up and serving hot dogs and lemonade.
myself.
But it also had me thinking.
So I don't think I talked about this.
But when I during MGSCon, I had the chance to go to a theme park I've never been to before.
And it was Knott's Berry Farm.
And guys, I can't stop thinking about that place either.
I had never been to Knott's Berry Farm.
before and it was it was so good oh my gosh I loved it I loved it I was too shy to meet Snoopy I was too shy to meet Snoopy but I went on every single big roller coaster and there was one roller coaster there that I can't stop thinking about called hang time and oh my gosh it was so oh my gosh so it's like a it's like a what's it called it's like a surfing theme surfing surfing theme roller coaster and at night at night it's lit up where so first you do like a 90 degree going up like you are your back and you're like going up the incline and you're like whoa my gosh that was my least favorite part i didn't like that and then then you like hang a little bit over the edge just so and then you're just kind of sitting there and you're like and then it drops you but the rest of the ride is so smooth it's so smooth and like the loops are kind of slow So,
like, you really feel like you're, like, riding a wave, and you're like, oh, like, oh, my gosh, it feels so good.
I can't stop thinking about that ride.
I can't stop thinking about Knott's Berry Farm, and I want to go back, and I want to ride Hang Time.
Oh, my God.
It's super duper smooth.
Ah, did you ride Ghost Rider?
I rode Ghost Rider.
I rode every roller coaster.
Because I love roller coasters.
Did you do accelerator?
Mm-hmm.
That's the one that's like mini King de Cot, right?
Yeah, I love roller coasters.
Was your butt also too big to fit in the seats, like shacks?
Yeah, pretty much.
Freaking Barry's tweet about that.
Also, Logan, thank you so much for the time, guys.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I love roller coasters.
Wait, King Dakar is dead now?
Aw, man.
Wait, I think I remember hearing about that, actually.
Yes, yes.
Curse of the big butt.
But yeah, I think even if you don't like roller coasters, I think hang time is really smooth.
The initial part is, like, really nerve-wracking, I'll be honest.
But the rest of the ride is so smooth and feels so good.
Feels so good.
Feels really like you're surfing.
Oh, I love, I love.
And then, I don't think I've ever heard of Knott's Berry Farm until now.
And then, this is also really cool.
They are originally a berry farm, so they grow the poison berries.
And I got to try so many different poison berry things.
I even got to try poison berry dip and dots.
Yeah!
I got that.
And then, um...
I tried some Boisenberry cheesecake.
And I had Boisenberry...
Bubble tea!
Oh, I forgot to move the notice.
My bad, hold on.
Wait, one second.
Back to where they were.
There we go.
Thank you!
Thanks, Logan.
And...
Um...
That was about what I ate.
If you're ever in Utah, somehow I highly recommend Lagoon.
Very fun and cool roller coasters.
I want to go to every amusement park, theme park in the world.
I feel cheated.
Nots was lame-o when I was a kid.
Oh, did they not have, like, the good rides?
No, it's good.
It's really good, and there's Snoopy?
Snoopy everywhere?
I really wanted a woodstock.
You know, he had the woodstock is the bird.
They had little woodstock headbands.
I wanted Snoopy ear headbands, but they only had, like, light-up ones, and they were hard and heavy.
And I wanted floppy Snoopy ears.
Vivi Korn, thanks for the gift.
Thank you.
And, uh, well, did I say your name right?
I hope so.
for the deck of the...
That's poisoned.
Bum, bum, bum.
Yeah.
Kids today don't know peanuts.
No, they will if they go to Knott's Berry Farm and they'll see Snoopy.
And I got to ride a couple Snoopy rides.
I was very happy.
One was like a little ride where you go through the camp with, you know, you see little Snoopy.
He's like, fish and you see other peanuts characters and they're like we're at the camp and we are we are having a camp competition and i was like so it's so cute it's so cute yeah um i went on one ride that was uh it was a snoopy roller coaster and it was so cute i and i liked it a lot it was so cute because they were they were they would have you go twice and when they pass you through the second time they're like one more time it was so cute
so and also the crowd there was like nobody there which it was really awesome and then at that And then that night, they had like this, they had like a live band.
And so I got to listen to that.
And they had like a jazz band and everything.
And there were people like, like, like swing dancing and stuff.
And it was really nice.
I was like, wait, this is, this is so cute.
And I went on a train and then I got, the train got attacked by people.
And it was so fun.
It was so fun.
I love theme parks.
Yeah.
Sounds like a really fun day.
It was.
If you ever get a chance to go to Knott's Berry Farm.
I recommend it so much.
It was so good.
Yeah, we were attacked by bandits.
They came and they were like, Hey, you got it.
You got where's your gold?
And I was like, um, I don't have any.
Yeah, I have.
That's, um...
I lied.
You see the trailer for that Snoopy mystery game?
No?
I didn't?
We love you, boys.
I love you.
You should have gone to Great America when you were at Off-Kai.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, yeah.
They're planning to close the park in 2027.
Well, that means next off, Kai, I could go.
My favorite there is Flight Deck.
It used to be called Top Gun.
There was, uh, there was another Top Gun ride.
Uh, oh gosh, I remember mmm, was it North Carolina?
South Carolina?
Some, some southern state.
I think?
There was a Top Gun ride.
I can't remember.
Carowins?
Was it?
The Carowins one?
Where is it?
Hold on.
I'm so bad at a map.
Okay, Carowins.
Yeah, Carowins North Carolina had the top gun ride.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
I knew there was another Top Gun, and I was sad because I didn't know about it until I liked Top Gun, and now I can't ever ride it.
It was so sad, but, you know, the bandits will remember you live.
Have you ever seen Carpet Bagger?
He makes YouTube videos about theme parks and roadside attractions.
He's a great person.
I've never seen him.
I'll check it out.
But yeah.
about it because I haven't been able to stop thinking about it today.
Yeah.
Aha.
I don't think I took any photos.
I don't think I did.
Oh, wait, no, that's a lie.
I took some pictures of Little Snake.
I took pictures of Snake with Snoopy.
I took pictures of Snake in jail.
I took pictures of Snoopy when I was When I was riding, the ride was Snoopy.
I took...
Those are the only pictures I took.
Oh, I took a picture of a tree.
That looked like a...
Like a hairless cat.
Yeah.
And there was also like a spooky looking lady.
I took a picture of her.
Those are the pictures.
I think I took a total of like 10 pictures.
Snake and Spooky Lady and Snoopy.
That's about it.
You guys want to see?
Hold on.
You want to see?
Let me get them from my phone.
Okay, one moment, please.
One moment, please.
Where?
Okay.
Oh, I took this picture.
Okay, hold on.
I think I can share this one of Snoopy.
I took a picture of Snake.
Took a picture of Snake.
Picture of Scary Lady.
And the tree.
Okay, one moment, please.
One moment, please.
Okay, now I must save the photos.
Oh, I have a picture of hang time.
Oh my gosh.
It's so good.
One moment, please.
Snake.
Um, uh, I need to crop this one.
I don't know.
There's people in the background.
I don't know who they are.
Creepy lady.
And hairless cat tree.
okay okay so this is where i went to nodsberry farm oh yeah hold on let me crop the people out i will keep your privacy people it doesn't you can see snoopy and snake just fine without them it's all good okie dokie ok so this is the oh here i'll start with the tree wait let me double check the tree because it was in a car so i want to make sure okay yeah yeah so this was not at the park but like okay you see it here look at this tree doesn't it look like a hairless cat doesn't it doesn't it look like a hairless cat i've never seen anything like it before why is it so wrinkly all the way down like texture wise yeah what else would I mean it looks like a hairless cat
you can see it yeah it needs a sensor bar I don't think it's that bad okay next is um snake with Snoopy and then we got Little Woodstock there.
I love Snoopy, so I was really excited to see Snoopy.
So cute, right?
And this bean is made by my friend Maddie.
Oh, that's Raspberry.
Yeah!
So I had to get pictures of Snake with Snoopy, my favorite people ever.
This is the scary lady.
She was so spooky, scary, scary lady next to the coffin.
Mm-hmm.
Scary, spooky.
It's just Matara.
Yeah, I see it.
Yeah, okay, Matara-Con.
Oh, Matara.
in jail oh he's varmint i was like no way it's ghost town jail varmint number 304 and a half they did have 305 but then this was the smaller one and i was like well snake is a little just a little bean so it's 304 and a half and then i was johnny and i was i was pretending i needed to ship myself I wasn't pretending and then um oh here's me with Snoopy on the Snoopy ride I was first row I um I didn't cut off a kid to get in first row but I definitely would have because I wanted to sit next to Snoopy
and he was driving really well he drove so good yeah it was our little our designated driver you're the real kid in this scenario I felt like a kid I felt like I was I was living my kid life and then and then this is hang time that roller coaster I was talking about earlier oh my gosh you can see the colors Okay.
So going up, I wish I had a pointer.
Hold on.
Let me get a pointer.
I'm going to use this party hat.
Okay.
Look at the tip of the party hat.
So here, this is like the incline, right?
You're on your back going up.
And this part is like kind of like a gold, like an orangey color.
And it's supposed to be like the sand.
And then you're over here.
And you're still in the sand.
And then you've got to go in this this is when this is this is when it turns blue and it looks like the water it's so so pretty at night i'd be terrified on the way up no i mean i was but right here is actually not so bad either and the drop the drop is not a 90 degree angle it's kind of like a little bit it's it's a little bit inward so the drop is not so bad you know if you really hate that pit that feeling in your tummy you don't really feel it because it's not like a you feel those kind of you feel that worse if it's like it's a little inverted so um yeah you don't feel it so bad the drop curves yeah yeah yeah yeah and so then you and it's really smooth it's so good but i just thought this was pretty yeah no it's very fun we're so cute okay let's my stories.
We can play the game now.
Thanks for listening to my stories.
But the incline is so bad.
The incline sucks.
Because it feels like you're about to fall, like it feels like you're gonna slip out because you're laying back so much, you know?
Ugh!
Zombie time!
click we're on episode whoa what's this guy's name again uh i can't remember
ben okay ben we're on the train baby wait were you really taking the train does the train work okay let's go yeah and duck on the side previously on the walking dead get the gates open we've got wounded i want to know why you thought bringing more mouths to feed was a good idea oh yeah all this happened my family you saved duck from those monsters and you stood up to larry at the drugstore and then we killed larry no one's trying to cut you out of anything those look like the people who raided my camp down your paranoia fuck you did you tell anyone out there who you were or that you were tied to this place that's right i know who you are you're a killer he's not dead somebody help me come on we know this guy's not gonna make it no sounds like a car it's a shitload of food and supplies back here are we just gonna ignore the cannibals that we met the rest of us are taking this stuff don't worry little girl bandits got their eye on that dairy as long as they keep getting food from them
you'll be safe
We're just gonna ignore the fact that we met a bunch of cannibals.
They're upset that I called it so quickly.
The game is mad.
They're like, you didn't guess it.
They just weren't that important.
The Walking Dead.
National Guard orders evacuation of city.
Is that a plane?
episode three long road ahead looks like this is our lucky day
oh maybe well this might go smoothly yeah this might actually go smoothly we deserve it we'll be an optimist it's a hindy
I forgot I have to be I've got to be ready for QTEs also thank you guys for the super task thank you so much thank you thank you
This is chapter 3, chapter 3.
Is that where you got it, Sean?
Where do you come down on staying or going?
You mean packing up the motel and getting in the RV?
Yeah, we've been talking about it, but have you made up your mind yet?
Um, we could split up.
We should go.
I want to go on an adventure.
Motels run its course, and it's not safe.
Yeah.
You're damn right it has.
We pile into the RV and don't pull over till we see water.
And if Lily's dead set on staying, then, well, that's the way it goes.
I mean, yeah, because now you know there's bandits in the area, I think, right?
Like, I wouldn't want to stay.
Okay, just like last time.
Over the rig, into the pharmacy, and scrape together whatever supplies are left.
Okay.
We didn't leave much in there.
Hey, we're out of options.
Something's better than nothing.
How would a zombie climb up?
Shit.
You okay?
ladders come loose.
I'm not sure how many more trips she's got in her.
I'm not sure how many more trips we've got in us.
No kidding.
Okay.
Look at the wind.
What else we got going on around here?
We got a Jeep.
We've got debris.
We got the... Oh, what else we got around here?
We got the Hmm, he's got a whole lot to say about this.
Oh, wait.
I just realized that this is the prescription.
Not prescription.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I read the prescription thing.
This is the place we start, like his family's drugstore, no?
They're blocked by all the fallen concrete.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I reckon.
Huh?
Doug.
Oh, Doug.
Oh.
Doug.
This is where we lost him.
Where we lost dog!
Oh my god!
D for dog!
D for dog.
Okay, I get it.
The Jeep is there.
I'm just observing right now.
Hello?
D for dog!
Yeah, me too.
look at helicopter so much for the military no good job guys debris there's no safe way through that mess Dennis guys I remember his name now okay oh what's this oh Kenny come on oh wait what about the Jeep shit damn it I can't reach you didn't even try sorry pal I'm All right,
stay put.
You didn't even try.
Oh, come on.
How did a zombie take down a helicopter?
Okay, but say that to Resident Evil as well, because the same exact thing happened.
Hmm.
Uh, uh, can I get in there?
Looks like it still works.
Okay.
this to Lily's not doing so good, huh?
She'll be fine.
Don't you dare forget Doug.
I won't.
I just don't know.
We attach it.
Okay.
Now what?
Oh my gosh, Douglas!
Doug!
Wait, do you think that was Doug's store?
No.
There's no way.
Oh.
Look at the control.
There we go.
Oh.
Your girl still upset me for taking stuff out of that car last week.
Uh.
I didn't take anything.
I hope not.
She'll get there.
I didn't take anything.
I was good.
You did that.
We will make diamonds out of him and carry him into battle.
My diamond duck.
I won't spread your ashes to the heartless Georgia.
Diamond duck.
I'm so taco, not the zombie making your parents divorce.
asking about that guy at hercial's farm last night really i wasn't sure it phased him of course it did oh um he'll get over it but still he'll get over it personal son is one of how many now we've all seen a lot worse he's a tough kid you know like i said not much phases him but it's starting to add up we are we are as cold as ice i need to get to the coast get him out of Ruthless.
Everybody gets over it.
You're sure you're up for this.
Lee, I'm fine.
I've got this.
Give me your hand.
I don't like the helicopter like over...
Kenny!
Uh...
Are you okay?
Jesus.
I'm fine.
Shit.
I'm sorry, pal.
I thought it'd be healed.
up better you're lucky it wasn't any worse you could have
oh my god she's uh she looks just as bad as them somebody help me stop screaming oh god what the what the hell is that a walker walkers don't scream do they jesus she looks so bad though uh uh it's we have to help her let's help her it's a girl there's no getting to her it's a lady Oh,
oh no, she's so dead.
Oh, never mind.
Fuck, we gotta shoot her.
Put her out of this misery.
So no, we're here.
What do you mean?
I mean, we leave her alive, and she draws them all to her.
Behind us, time.
Yeah, think about it.
We're always worrying about the ones we can't see.
She stays alive and brings them all out of their holes.
Yeah, she's a goner.
Where did they all come from?
watch what happens oh she's turning around to look at us they're so slow just run go now
just moving at you
But she got bit.
We can't do anything.
We should be good to clear this place out.
But we ain't got all day.
Get everything you can out of these racks.
How is she still alive?
Don't forget underneath the counter this time.
I'll clear down here and then we gotta go.
I can't with her.
Go away!
Oh my god.
She's gone.
There's not much time now.
Uh-oh.
Wait, how do they know we're here?
Do they know?
How do they know?
Oh, there's more.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
I'm grabbing.
Oh, gosh.
There's not much time.
I'm grabbing everything that I can.
Supplies.
There's supplies.
There's more?
Oh, my gosh.
There's even more.
Medicine box.
Uh, open.
Oh, energy bar.
Give me the food.
Supplies.
I am being greeted.
I'm being under a mega greet.
How do they know?
Fuck!
Incoming!
Come on, Lee!
Okay.
Up and over.
Oh, you can do that, huh?
Still clear.
Let's hustle.
Oh my gosh.
Kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip.
Kip, I'm pressing, I'm pressing, pressing.
Kini!
Kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip, kip!
Fridge!
Freeze!
Oh, Fridge!
Get out!
Let's fucking get out!
Yeah, I think so too.
Okay, go.
Run, run, run, run.
Oh, not the pilot!
Here!
How did she lure them all to...
us so quickly?
What are all these arrows?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, we're getting a attacked by the people so much?
Also, they said that they didn't, like, clear out the pharmacy, but there was still a lot of stuff.
I'm not gonna lie.
The bandits are insane.
Aw, Clem.
You're back.
Ben found some stickers in a drawer and I put them on my walkie.
So cute.
Hey, sweet pea.
That's neat.
I'll find you in a minute.
So cute.
He's so cute.
Hi.
Looks like we got the kid on watch again.
What'd you get?
Might as well leave a sign out that says the men are going and come and rape our women and children.
Huh.
So, what did you get?
Uh, uh, what was left?
Just what was left.
Which was a lot, actually.
Take a look.
Kenny, chill.
Chill, Kenny.
We're fine, by the way.
Nice work.
This will keep us going.
If we carry on like this, we'll get through the winter here.
The winter?
What?
We'll freeze our asses off here.
Right, yeah, what?
Just piling into an RV with you, too, after what you did to my dad is so appealing.
You can leave.
You know, I'll do what it takes to keep everyone safe.
We're already safe.
We do whatever is best for the kids.
That's not graffiti.
Those are bullet holes.
And we got enough arrow shafts sticking out of it to dry our life.
if you say that we do whatever is best for the kids yeah doesn't that make sense yeah it's suicide out there we'll die in here you're right you could see someone sleeping and kill one of us sleeping okay girl girl let's not be dramatic don't boss your dad was i'm sorry somebody needs to make executive decisions for the group though and i don't think you're capable anymore don't start with yeah you're gonna stop everything can't come down to the same disagreement we're gonna be points here yeah i'm so tired of it being you two versus damn it i'm not on anyone's side lily these decisions affect everyone what about the food situation what about protection what about when this place falls somebody's got to be thinking about this how has this not been working we have everything we need because of me lily that's bs k we got and you we got plenty of food from that station wagon you didn't even want to take it oh wait where the hell would we be now i forgot not the station i just keep our
fingers crossed from station wagons everything that happens to us is another excuse for you to pull this crap about leaving all I want is a week of peace of not hearing it do you know how we got these supplies we got lucky let a girl get out there what some girl came screaming out of an alley she had dead hanging all over her she gave us enough time to get everything we could out of the drugstore and you just let suffer like what like bait oh god what is happening well i mean she was dead you guys couldn't try to save her don't take that tone with him she was dead kenny why did you tell them that it made the most sense in the morning why did you tell him that kenny wait a second kenny putting our lives on the line doing these runs into the city kenny you're making us look the shit we see we all appreciate it ken you should be thanking lee for not shooting that girl it's not so easy for him Look,
Makin and its people aren't savable.
It's not a town.
It's full of walkers.
And the people who were left are dying and wandering out onto the streets.
It's hell on earth, and it's coming this way.
It's not going to be easier out on the road.
How would you know?
What I know?
I know you're not above murder.
I know somebody has been stealing our supplies.
That's right.
Stealing!
And I know the list of people I can trust here gets smaller every day.
Everybody get out!
I think it's Ben.
Ben is stealing.
I don't trust that guy.
We don't know him.
Uh, she'll get over it.
She'll get over it.
She's riling everybody up, otherwise.
You understand.
She's right about one thing.
I love being called cool as a pickle.
Yeah, they'll get over it.
That's my solution to everything.
They'll get over it.
Things are coming to a head.
Oh my gosh.
You could say that.
I would say it's safer here.
Well, I think you did good today.
And I find myself thinking that most days.
If not for the bandits.
You know?
Thanks.
It's probably worth following up with Lily about what she was saying about missing supplies.
With her wound up the way she is, I don't want to see her paranoid.
I think Doug would have touched us that way.
No question.
And I'd like to talk when you've got a minute.
Hmm.
Maybe.
when in doubt choose they'll get over it yeah no i think staying here would probably be a safer option if not for the bandits you know like they're literally like you saw the number of arrows and everything in in the walls and the bullet holes there's no way you can stay here there's no way i would say something like maybe like knocking down one of the fences like if you did stay you could knock down like a part of the fence and rebuild it to include a garden but yeah i think it's i think we gotta go i think we gotta go
they can't aim you're safe hey you two how are you doing we're okay just having a little spat uh-oh we all carry guns I don't like it it's the way it's got to be it is I know but I'm not getting used to it I'm sorry how are you I'm in um I think you just gotta get I think you guys just gotta get over it I think you just gotta like I don't know ma'am anyway she'll be fine you need to try harder with Lily you guys got a straightness huh actually I think I don't know how straight we can get it given all that's happened so what then time will come we'll have to do its best for our families and that's what we'll do you guys trust everyone here you guys uh trust everyone here no more or less I obviously have my problems with Lily but I don't distrust her yeah she's annoying we can't turn on each other any more than we have I don't you know she doesn't seem bad about the About the guns.
Don't you start.
I just wanted to say, Kat, it's probably good they make you uncomfortable.
Thank you, Lee.
Oh, Kenny will remember that.
But we need them.
There's no doubt about that.
I'll talk to you later.
Kenny will remember that.
Kenny, you need to calm down a little bit, man.
You're making me, you're making, we're bros, but like, bros will also slap some sense into each other.
Hi, Lee.
Hi.
Where's...
Oh, where's Duck?
Duck.
Oh, Duck.
Sounds like Kenny actually has that thing running.
He'll get over it.
I'll believe it when I see it.
Hello, Ben.
Hey, Ben.
What's up, Lee?
See anything weird?
Yeah.
Have you seen anything weird on watch?
Is there anybody out there up to anything?
Nope.
Really quiet.
Yeah, totally.
Which is good.
Yeah.
Did you ever come down to Macon much?
Did you ever come down here to Macon much?
I didn't have much reason to.
My parents would let me take the car into the city on the weekend.
But what's in Macon?
People in Macon make Macon?
It's kind of a waste of time compared to Atlanta.
I grew up in Macon.
Oh.
I didn't mean to say it's crappy or anything.
It's super nice.
I mean, not now, but I bet it was.
Is.
Nah, we get you.
What do you think about Lily?
Hello?
She scares the crap out of me.
That's a reasonable thing to feed.
I'm just worried she's going to snap.
Talk to you later, Ben.
Bye.
That is a reasonable...
You know what?
That's a reasonable fear.
Nah, she'll get over it.
has a problem.
I miss the part when that's my problem.
Oh cute!
There's even bullet holes here.
That's not us, right?
We're moonwalking?
Not again.
For anybody that doesn't know, I'm obsessed with that.
With, with bully Peter Parker.
When he's like, I miss the part where that's my problem.
I love that.
Bully McGuire.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bully McGuire is so funny.
Clementine.
Hey, Clementine.
Hey, Lee.
Whatcha doing?
What's that you're working on, Clem?
Where's Doug?
It's called a leaf rubbing.
My teacher, Miss Moore, showed us how to do him when we went to the botanical garden once.
She's so smart.
See, it's the same.
Um, kind of.
Oh, that's really something.
I'll make one for you too.
She's so sweet.
She's so, she's so precious.
Oh, Clem, oh, Clementine, I love you so much.
Look, he's hiding in the shadows.
He's waiting to torment her more.
Do you like it here?
I don't like it here.
Yeah, so.
Do you want to leave?
Where are we going?
somewhere else I don't know maybe if I knew where yeah that'd be a good thing to know let's go to the beach later clan okay I think if we told her we're going to the beach she would be very excited okay okay what was that when there was one movie I think it was the quiet place movie talk to Lily she has a cat and no not yet I will What I wanted to say was,
I've been thinking a lot about you.
Confession?
I think about you too.
Our group is small.
You're small.
Why would you say that?
You're a convicted killer.
Hello?
Carly.
Jesus.
And I think people should know.
Not because they deserve to.
and not because you're a bad man I think the opposite of those two people need to know because we're hanging by a thread here and I can't see Lily talk about you without thinking it's the next thing she's going to say you don't have to tell everyone but think about who you trust and take the opportunity while you have it me I've been stop we'll listen to her I like her you're probably right of course I'm probably right.
I don't think Kenny is going to like us, though.
I don't think...
People might be pissed, though.
But it will be a far cry from what will happen if they don't hear it from you.
Yeah, that's true.
Unless we kill everybody who knows.
Carly.
Just think.
This could be Doug confessing to you right now.
I'll let people know.
You're totally right.
Good.
I think it's for the best.
Women aren't strong.
Just me.
Don't call me small.
Don't call me Shirley.
Is there anything else you want to talk about?
You guys, I think we're in.
I think we're in.
It should have been Doug.
You think people are ready to hear about me?
You really think people are ready to hear about me?
It's not a matter of ready or not.
She doesn't seem that small.
But there are going to be a lot of bad ones.
Why do you say that?
seem like one of them but everyone's different who knows how each person would take it you know maybe it's worth thinking about who you want to tell she seems she's like average height completely i don't get it oh my gosh do you feel safe here show me a bath with a heated floor in a high-rise apartment and hand me a full-bodied malbec and then i'll feel safe i don't know this place is heated floors okay she's bougie i could change it any second Rizter with batteries,
dolly.
I watched a video today.
Sometimes, you know how people will travel different airlines and try their first class or their business class or whatever.
I watched a video today about Emirates first class.
Good golly, is that like actually insane?
But I learned that the bathrooms in the Emirates first class heated floors.
That seems like the most, like, it seems like the most, like the top of the top of what you could buy if you have money.
Like, because you don't need heated floors.
Like, I wear slippers or socks everywhere, but like, people who have, who go through the extra effort of heated floors, it feels like the most, if you don't need it, it feels like the most bougie thing I've heard of them in my afterlife like for real Carly is 5'6 Lee is around 6'2 so she's tall for 2008 yeah what the heck then who's walking in there barefoot ah so I have no idea it's kind of scary I don't want to think about that yeah I just wear slippers everywhere but I guess if you also live in like a really like i'm not saying it's not probably a necessity everywhere you know what i mean but like if you don't need it if you're just like uh like an airplane does not need heated floors if you are you know like if you're just like ah i'm just give me my heated floors like ma'am this is Georgia.
It's the most like...
You are one state above Florida.
Don't act like you need that.
Jeez.
Anyway, you have any thoughts about Lily?
You have any thoughts about Lily?
I worry about her.
Back in 2012 and 13 years later.
She keeps trying to run things, but it's just not working.
I'm going to look into this thing.
Good idea.
Okay.
Bye, Carly.
Thanks for the kiss.
Is she in there?
Okay, Lily is in there.
I guess let's go tell.
You think he's going to hate me?
When I used to work on boilers, I had a customer with heated floors and Egyptian artifacts behind glass.
The husband worked in advertising, apparently.
advertising for who the mafia holy cow oh lily okay i'm sorry you don't have to apologize did you come in here to give me hell or to coddle me you're coming unhinged you have to chill out you have to chill out yeah i think you do girl i'm not going to play the victim but you and your buddy might have had a hand in my instability Can I do anything for you?
Haven't you...
No.
Yes.
I could use your help.
There's a traitor.
Somebody.
One of us.
Out there.
He or she or they have been taking things.
Uh...
Who?
For real.
What do you got?
Yes, for real.
And I don't have shit.
I just know.
Lily.
It counts often.
It's the good stuff.
Antibiotics.
Oxi.
anything with opium in it i see the count and it's fine i keep my own that one's getting messed with i'm a mess right now but i'm not stupid i know what happens if i start a witch hunt so you want me to start one i want you to poke around poke around what's there to go on opium it's i found this tossed into the garbage huh we don't toss out equipment we fix it you don't try to get rid of a flashlight if you're using it when you shouldn't oh she's smart I'll poke around okay I'll poke around a little bit I'll poke around thank you if you don't find anything I'm just going to assume it's you what ma'am okay never mind maybe it's you mystery oh god it's duck Jesus duck I'm sorry I'm sorry i heard you guys talking i don't know how i want to hear my words can i help what did i just say you're the greatest detective and i can be dick greasing your ward that's robin i know who it is uh fine you're robin okay you're robin here's another type of bird what do i do do?
I don't know.
Go look around.
Let me know if you find anything weird.
I feel like Duck is going to be the one to solve this.
I feel like Duck is going to find something.
Duck detective.
Duck will help is what it says.
Oh my gosh.
Duck detective.
I'm going to tell well, hold on.
Let's talk to Kenny.
about a broken flat you guys know anything about this broken flashlight fuck we don't got many of those yeah it's a problem the glass and the bulb are all busted out I saw some broken glass over by the ice machine I meant to clean it up before the kids hurt themselves on it I forgot though uh should we talk to them what do we think I'll talk to you later let's go talk to Ben I don't know he I don't I don't know
a flashlight was broken was it you no you're not in trouble if it was no you get nervous and maybe you went out to go to the bathroom okay i'll talk to them okay i'll talk to them what's with the third degree i didn't break any flashlight okay then i'll tell him first then staff welcome the membership thank you hey ben i need to tell you something surely is it about my surely i told you
I'm a convicted murderer.
Um, uh...
I was, uh, on my way to prison before this.
Whoa, seriously?
What, um, were you in for?
Murder.
It's not important.
Oh.
Just, if you hear anything, it's probably true.
And now you know.
Thanks for trusting me, man.
I...
Uh...
Ben, relax.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, all right, let's go tell him.
Kenny.
Kenny, you got a second?
I need to tell you something.
Can I tell them both at the same time?
Oh, oh, oh.
It's serious.
Oh, no.
What the she-devil do to you?
Shut up, man.
I'll say I'll do the same thing I was on my way to prison three months ago no shit no shit it wasn't for touching kids was it oh man come on man he looked me up and down he looked me up and down the guy in a fight hmm must have been a real piece of shit if you had to haul off and kill him oh he trusts us so we're straight then Lee look at everything this mess has got us doing now I'm sorry you went through whatever you went through yeah we're straight is so unhinged dang we're happy oh we're happy Kenny appreciates your honesty we're happy about it I wouldn't say Kenny is wholesome I think I think I think I think he is keeping it real I think he's keeping it real with us I don't want to say a whole song can I talk to you about something sure is everything okay he knows he knows look at that gamer slouch goodness um I was on my way to prison three months ago I was uh on my way to prison Kenny does not care you've always looked at me with kind eyes I wonder if you could still do that if
you uh what forgiveness knew i was a convicted felon my goodness for what how much trouble can a teacher get into well plenty but it had nothing to do with that it was for murder why he and my wife that's enough tell me what happened when you were locked in the fridge at the dairy what what happened when i was locked in the fridge at the dairy Oh,
with Larry.
Oh,
I just told her that I killed some...
Wait, but then she'll know that...
I didn't kill Larry.
Kenny killed Larry.
Oh, I don't think I should.
I don't think I should.
I think we should take the fall.
Tell her, you think so?
Okay.
I held Lily back, and Kenny made sure Larry didn't get up.
What did he do?
He smashed his head in.
I think I'm ruining their marriage.
I think I...
I think I just caused a divorce.
Gotcha.
Everything's fine.
thing keeps changing she'll get over it oh
no I think she is unhappy gotcha we'll remember that I think I think we oh hey find anything oh wait um I need to tell you something I need to tell you something what is it
I was sent to prison before the plague you think that's news I guess I hoped it was worse did you think that story died with my dad no anything else well I figured he told her but you know okay we just Lily won't forget that it's a shame you can't go to bat forgetting like Larry was already dead I know like why didn't we explain that like he like was going to die and then change into a zombie and that we had to you know i feel like that's a very crucial part we didn't just bust larry's head in because we felt like it hey clementine hey lee you didn't accidentally break a flashlight did you no did duck say i did no did uh duck break the flashlight i don't think so he's just always blaming me for stuff I suck putting a bug on his pillow did you do that yes yeah Clementine that's my girl that's my girl Clem I need to talk to you for a second wait but she knows you should know the day you and I met I was in a car accident she knows though I remember your leg was bleeding yeah the car I was
in was a police car and i was on my way to jail for committing a crime i need to tell you now because i don't want you to hear it any other way okay do you have anything to say i don't think so you can uh go on back to your things clementine understands what you did
Okay, so I wanted to come over here because she said by the ice maker, here we go, the broken glass.
There's some broken glass on the ground there.
Inspect it.
Oh.
Hmm.
What is that?
Wait.
There's something drawn there.
Hmm.
Chalk.
Oh gosh, duck!
A clue!
Maybe.
She's the only well-adjusted adult here.
What do you think it is?
I don't think it's anything.
Maybe it's a sign.
It could be.
It's pink chalk, which is weird.
Okay, back to investigating.
What is this, like, funky music side plot?
Man.
there's no pink on the ground like that's orange yeah there's no pink definitely weird huh huh duck detective where is he sounds like Kenny actually has that thing running I believe it when I see it about the chalk hey Ben I need a piece Chuck you know where I can get any why would I have any just asking around well I don't play with that stuff I've got my well my thoughts and I've been reading the Bible I found in my room he's got his thoughts what it's there for I've been reading yeah idiot you you have that and you read it I like how we we can't even ask Carly about the X.
We just immediately trust her.
I think we're in love.
Have you seen any chalk around?
Ah, yes.
Clementine loves to draw with it.
Yeah, of course.
I'll talk to her.
Yeah.
Pink chalk.
Maybe it went missing.
Hey, Clementine.
It's Clementine.
Do you have any pink chalk?
No.
It's gone somewhere.
Hmm.
Do you want blue?
No, no, it's okay.
Wait, so whoever has the pink chalk.
Lee.
I found something.
What is it?
I found this piece of pink chalk and a scuff of it over by the gate.
Where?
Oh, really?
Totally.
I was coming to see him for clues.
Yeah, Duck, I got it.
Good job.
Oh, let the kid talk.
Oh, there.
What is it?
Oh, he's miming?
Oh, you can have it.
guys do we leave him
i'm sorry look at him look at you
oh you didn't break the flashlight did you duck no i didn't know it was time i didn't know it was time that's probably for the best oh my gosh anything else?
Just the chalk.
I also found some bugs underneath the stairs.
Don't tell Clementine.
Okay, I won't.
Restart the run.
I'm sorry.
I will pay for my words and my deeds.
You seem to know a bit about all of this.
The chalk?
You found the scuff here?
His eyes.
This is going to sound crazy, but you're not involved, are you?
i'm a good guy stay inside the gate i'm a good guy i will okay looking at more chalk yeah
i don't think we should go out though uh
somebody was over here too see i did good huh yeah duck you did i suppose i should go out there and look around oh don't stay here this time seriously okay okay i'm scared to go out
okay um those bandits gave us hell but they've been quiet for days now that's scary a moonwalking oh oh interesting okay there's a great down there Yeah.
Interesting.
It's a bag of something.
Oh.
Is it...
Oh!
Is it full of pills?
Son of a bitch.
Uh-oh.
You haven't come up with anything, have you?
I came up with this.
It's got a bunch of meds in it.
It was in a grate on the outside wall.
And there's a sign on the other one.
Holy fuck.
Yeah.
What?
Okay, we line everybody up.
Everybody.
Somebody is killing us.
Stealing from that supply is the same as slipping into your room at night and cutting your throat while you sleep.
Whoa, whoa.
You die.
What is the difference?
What if Clementine gets sick and we don't have what we need?
What the hell like oxy?
You don't fucking steal from us!
Who the fuck is that?
Got our people out there!
Oh my god!
We're fucking around!
Not the bandits!
Shit!
They're gonna start kicking indoors any second.
Lily, what the hell are you- Wait, what?
Just keep them talking.
Do whatever it takes to stop him pulling the trigger.
You made the biggest mistake of your life!
Oh no!
Oh gosh, okay.
Okay, no pressure.
Enough of this bullshit!
Stop putting your boot to these doors.
Yeah.
Hold it, asshole.
Take it easy.
Yeah, his shirt says hard ass.
Um, oh.
We have more supplies.
We can keep the deal going.
Too late, shithead.
We ain't giving second chances.
What deal?
It was a mix-up.
We'll make it worth your while.
I'm listening.
Oh, oh, um, what will it...
What will it take to reach a deal?
Yeah, yeah.
About twice as much as you've been.
given us.
You got it.
Done.
Is that so?
Well, I suppose we ought to hash out some terms then.
I don't like no hash.
Man, shut up, bro!
Christ!
Oh, shit!
I don't like no hash.
Oh, she's got a good shot.
Get him!
I got him in the butt.
Oh.
Oh, no!
Oh, no, oh, no!
Get back there.
Smoke him out!
We got to get out of here.
No shit.
Get those bastards.
Cover our people and get them to the RV.
Oh, my God.
Uh.
Oh.
Go around, shit for brains.
He's back there.
Oh, wow.
Nice shot me.
Now, get over here.
Hurry.
Man, you saved our assets.
Get inside.
Time crisis.
Cloud!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Gotcha, hang on!
And there's zombies!
Where is he?
Oh my gosh.
Gotcha!
Hurry, come on!
Clip, get inside the RV.
It's gonna be okay, go!
Oh my god.
Oh Christ.
Lily, get in the RV.
Screw her.
Let her stay.
Lily!
Shit!
Well, I have to do this now.
A or D?
Oh, okay.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Other side?
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
How long do I have to do this?
Oh, my goodness.
Last chance.
Get down here.
Free earth foot licker.
Thank you so much for the What was
the point of me shooting at them?
Jesus, are you okay?
I'm fine.
Duck is not looking so good.
I'm sorry.
Everything's fine.
Everything's not fine.
Ben.
You need to figure out how this happened.
You just lost everything.
Ben.
Well, we're lucky as shit to have this RV.
And nobody died.
Cat's head is split open.
I'm fine.
Duck is...
Duck's eyes are rolling into the back of his head.
The bandits have had our number for weeks.
This is different.
somebody was working with them whoever it was was slipping them our meds they didn't get their last package so they attacked calm down back there that's nuts Lee found a bag of supplies hidden outside the wall it's true so Carly then was the one watching watch to say it has to be it has to be we have to get it out of you then back off he were in no position to make demands my aim whoa whoa you're just pointing fingers i didn't just come up with this i've had my suspicions probably not the best time carly's trustworthy that's our girl that's our girl thank you lee she can fight her own battles unless there's something going on here that implicates you both don't be ridiculous like look maybe we should vote or something like that vote what just look carly's a stand-up gal and maybe this was all just a mistake to look at the facts let's calm down we'll eat and we'll deal with it yeah let's do that let me stop waving the finger at everybody i don't know we know something's going on and we
can get to the bottom of it if we keep our heads i know what we found i know lily i know it's ben he was the one keeping anything was it both of you what i've seen you two together was it both of you look just let me out i didn't do it but i don't like I don't like where it's headed.
Look me in the eyes and tell me you didn't have anything to do with it.
Voting duck.
Will we lay off of him?
I...
Oh shit!
What's going on up there?
I hit something.
We gotta stop.
Oh.
Well, we can deal with this now then.
Oh my god!
What do you mean you hit something?
Kitty, is it safe?
Should be.
Everybody out.
Think we know what you hit?
Out.
Oh, good.
Right next to another car, though.
There might be supplies.
Ew, you can hear it.
Kenny, you have, like, one job.
Kenny, the RV has some surface damage, but there's a walker trapped underneath.
God damn it.
everyone keep your eyes peeled okay you know what we shouldn't just kick you out we should hear what everybody thinks i think you should chill out i think we should stop yelling this you can push ben around but you can't push me around i'm really sorry you feel that way i'm starting to think maybe it was both of you no just dumb walker you okay over there there's no way it was carly yeah somebody else it could have even been someone sneaking into our camp that's ridiculous That's what you think?
Okay, fine then.
Why do I think that?
Kenny?
I don't know.
Fuck.
Just stop, would you?
Well, your vote counts for you and Kacha.
We don't need all these votes.
You said to vote!
Trust me.
I'll do anything.
I'll do watches for months.
Huh.
The hell you will.
I'll get more food.
More medicine.
Anything.
You think any of that is good now?
Just let me stay, please.
God, please.
You have better.
It was your idea to vote.
Look at you.
Okay, you're making it worse, man.
You're making it worse on yourself.
I just don't want to be on my own.
You should have thought of that.
Do we need any more evidence than this?
Fuck evidence.
Stop treating him like this.
Shut up, Connie.
Wait a second, though.
I've heard enough out of you.
Kenny, what's it going to be?
Just give me a damn minute.
Then, you have until that Walker is dealt with to tell me it was her and not you.
Stop this.
You're torturing him.
No!
This is about trust, and I've never trusted you.
Lily, are you off?
I can't, Lee.
You know I can't.
Thank you, Lee.
Please, listen to him.
Please don't kick me out of the group.
We won't.
Tell me.
Now.
Why doesn't she think it was Kenny?
I've got him, he's.
Let's just get back in the RV.
You think you're some tough bitch, don't you?
Like nothing can hurt you.
But you're just a scared little girl.
Get the fuck over it.
Take a page from Lee's book and try helping somebody.
once she's about to attack her she's gonna that's what she wants to do to her now um what the fuck's the problem drop
it holy Kenny what's happening duck away from the windows Jesus Christ oh Clementine get in we're leaving this crazy she couldn't be trusted Lee I swear.
Please.
What are we gonna do with her?
Leave her for the walkers.
You're not coming with us.
I'll die out here.
No, yeah, we leave her.
You're a murderer, Lily.
We can't have you with us.
I'm a murderer.
You've had Lee with you this whole time.
I don't care what he did before.
If we keep you with us, how long until you get me?
I was trying to protect all of us.
I don't have anything left.
Get in, Lee.
Let's go, you guys.
Girl, you can't be acting like the victim right now.
I suppose they should get over it.
She's acting like the victim.
You resorted to the worst thing.
Lily.
by god lee a word please carly carly are you okay katya needs you for something
are we were gonna she kissed us what's up is duck feeling all right is duck okay wait is he actually not okay what the fuck i was too slow i was too slow wait wait he's gonna turn we don't know that gotcha what do we really know none of us have been bitten we don't know what the time frame is for a child we know nothing no gf route i'm going to monitor him and focus on the wound and no see if his condition changes oh my god we keep the same plan his eyes were really rolling back into his no what else
important to stay honest with each other keep your eyes on the road mister anyway if you could tell clementine we would appreciate it yeah gag him yeah like like like bind him or something so that he doesn't it's because he lives to beg me we're all gonna be stuck with Ben everybody else is God and we're gonna be stuck with him oh man this is the worst First run ever.
Duck is bitten.
Huh?
He got bit by a walker trying to escape the motel.
I was too slow.
I don't feel good.
Clem?
Clem, don't say that.
What about Carly?
Gone, but won't come back.
Because she was shot in the head.
That's right.
Yeah, it is.
It is.
If
we had saved Doug.
I'm glad I have you.
Me too.
I heard you outside my treehouse that day and thought about dropping a hammer on your head.
Good girl.
That's nice.
I didn't though.
She's she's protecting herself.
Yeah, good instincts, exactly.
Banana.
Oh, God.
Wait, what?
This is a dream.
Okay.
I knew it.
We got something up ahead.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Wait, but he still hasn't turned?
They really tried to redeem Duck with the cute little detective thing, and then they killed him.
That's crazy!
They were like, yo, you...
You know, Duck's been annoying this whole time, but he's actually quite cute.
Oh my gosh.
Is there any way to get around it?
Doesn't look like it.
On foot, maybe.
Can't really afford to do that now.
I guess it was like a kind of a death flag in its own way.
This seems like a safe area.
Well, this brush will stop anything from creeping up on us.
What?
Oh!
Why don't you and I go look around?
Yeah, everyone else relax.
Clem, stay close to Kinney and Cat, okay?
But not Duck.
Lee, if you come across anything to drink, if there's a dining car or something, I think Duck's a bit dehydrated.
It's a freighter, huh?
Be careful in there.
What?
You think there might be something dangerous inside an abandoned locomotive?
Hadn't crossed my mind.
okay exciting train box car ladder we'll talk to Ben I think duck is dead I think so yeah duck is thirsty for blood was it you was it you not this again I'm just asking no okay then I don't know I feel like Ben won't forget that.
Don't worry, Minto, the protagonist.
Ben is still alive.
Happy you stayed with us all this time.
What would you have done with Lily?
I don't know.
Left her?
I've never seen anybody kill someone like that before.
You've seen a bunch of other stuff by now.
Yeah, but not like that.
you uh happy you stayed with us all this time yeah really it's with you guys are dead I would have died out there in the woods that's true like my classmates you think this is better yeah of course I don't know it's true it's true hey sweet pea you okay out here oh I don't think duck feels good me neither I don't think she should keep him so close you know hey man we're still looking around and haven't figured much out yet it's fine radiator could use a rest as it is that's fair oh gosh how's duck how's duck I was too slow tired which could mean a lot of things right yeah I thought I was so fast with the zombies.
Has Clementine said anything to you about Connie and Duck or anything?
I'm worried about her.
No.
That little girl is a puzzle.
Yeah, she is.
She's a poor Carly.
She's not a puzzle.
God, where did yesterday go?
I know.
My gosh.
I don't know.
are you my gosh I know you were fond of her I'm used to it I'll be fine I'm fine don't worry about me I do don't I liked her but she's gone now no I'm sorry Lee we got over it we're over it a fellow Ben checking in This Ben is bringing down all the other Ben's in the world.
Please do not let him solely our good name
Uh-oh Seems like all the Ben's need to vote a Ben out Benjamin Would you have left Lily back there on the side of the road like that?
Yes, Lee.
Yeah We have to have lines.
Yes, I would have left her.
That's very true If Katya says it's okay, then I think it's okay.
Let me know if anything changes here.
She's probably the best moral compass here.
Oh, wait.
Kani.
Oh, wait, I did talk to Kani.
Still looking around and haven't figured much out yet.
It's fine.
Radiator could use a rest as it is.
Sorry, I forgot Kani didn't have anything to say.
Okay, let's go check out the car.
Wait, should I go inside?
It's kind of scary.
But what if Lily was right?
that it was Carly?
I don't know.
Anybody in here?
Oh gosh, the whimsy music stopped.
Oh no, scary music started.
Oh, this place looks...
Yeah, it's us.
Yeah, man.
Shit, think they're gone?
I hope so, but this looks recently used.
Be on the lookout and have you gone.
It smells recently used.
We changed Ben's name to Shirley.
Looks unopened.
Um, okay.
I'll take this to Katja for Dutch.
Oh, that's right.
He's thirsty.
Look at the map.
A clipboard.
A map of where the train goes.
I think these tracks might lead to the coast.
Oh!
27 Savannah.
That's where Kenny's got us headed.
Okay, nice.
Yikes, this mattress.
Okay.
The frog magazine?
I thought it was dog food.
Okay, okay.
I was like, can I do anything here?
Engine compartment.
Might be something inside.
Okay.
Ozombo.
I'm ready?
Oh, okay, never mind.
Uh.
Switch.
Nintendo.
Frog food.
Is there a zombo in here?
Okay, we got some spike removers.
I'll take that.
Bintendo.
A minkey wrench.
I'll take that.
Just kidding, I can only have one.
Okay, we'll just hold on to it for now.
now.
Minky!
Might be something inside.
There we go.
Nuh-uh.
Time to build a water park.
Yahoo!
This seems like it's going to be a pain in the butt because we have to open the doors and do the cuts.
If I have to open doors multiple times, it's going to be kind of annoying.
Oh, that's...
Shit.
It's shot in the head.
I think it's okay.
We got one.
No, no, I think it's...
Sitting in the chair.
No, it's head.
Oh.
Is he alive?
Use monkey wrench.
Is it awake?
Maybe not.
A sitter.
Yeah, he's not doing anything.
That guy's dead dead.
Suppose we all look him over.
Oh.
Examine him.
Oh, is little of the photo of his family?
I don't think this guy came back.
Oh.
That light is blinking.
Push it.
Why not?
Are you fucking serious?
Here, look.
Oh, Ben!
Ben!
It's just the brakes.
Okay, I'll give you that one.
This fucker works?
Seems like it.
Oh my goodness.
How the hell do we get it moving?
Explosion button.
I don't know.
That's Mr. Amtrak over here.
No clue.
We found this in the box car back there.
Yeah.
Whoa, is this what it looks like?
I think so.
This horse will take us right to Savannah.
A hundred tons of steel.
Put a thousand walkers between us and the ocean, and we don't have to give a shit.
That's true.
I can't believe it.
Uh, I wouldn't, yeah.
I wouldn't mind plowing through some walkers.
Hell yeah.
That's the spirit.
Try to get this thing started.
There's gotta be some sort of manual or something.
Huh, I don't know about that.
The nuke button for the train.
Man, if you could keep an eye on the girls and duck, I'd appreciate it.
I won't make sense of these controls.
Someone should have played train simulator.
Man, this could be exactly what we need.
Yeah.
hey kid what's up no Ben that's the blow up the whole train button every train has one every train has one because who knows if he need to I don't know about leaving Lily back there now I knew abandoning someone on the side of the room it's the same as murder don't worry about it we just would have had to deal with her eventually you want to talk about duck you want to talk about duck why did i slide in nobody deserves this there's nothing to talk about you heard cat he could be fine we probably shouldn't ignore it nobody's ignoring nothing i'm not worried you shouldn't be either
yeah yeah we needed something to help us god we need some help getting this train going people take notes right when working on stuff like this We're smart guys, we can figure it out.
Yeah, okay.
I'll get back to it.
Me too.
Oh, there's that.
The map bin.
A bunch of maps about Georgia's cities.
Nothing about the tree.
Oh, that's a picture.
Look at this boat.
Oh, here we go.
Shit, this is it.
Instructions on starting the engine.
Engines.
Damn.
Pages are gone.
No, how convenient.
I can kind of see the engine.
The Rizzler?
Wait!
Clem!
Find a way to read the notebook.
We gotta talk to Clementine.
She knows the leaf rubbing.
Okay.
Give me down.
And let's go give the water bottle to...
Do you think I should put a little drop of blood in there?
For... for, uh...
For duck?
You think it was?
You think get his palette ready?
We found a notebook that we think might have had some starter directions on it, but the page is missing.
Some sugar.
I'm sure you guys will figure it out.
Hey, you too.
There's a notepad on the train.
Do you have any pencils or anything in your pack?
No, I wish.
Maybe in the RV.
What do you need it for?
There used to be something written on the notepad that I need to know about.
Well, if you're not using it, I'd take it.
I'm out of paper and there's all sorts of new leaves around here.
She wants some leaves.
Okay.
Here, found some water.
Oh, thank you.
Perfect.
He's allergic to bees.
Is that right?
It's all I can keep thinking about.
Like, somehow that matters.
He doesn't.
He doesn't look good.
I know.
Well, I don't.
But you're probably right.
oh he's also allergic to zombies
i better get back to it is ken all right what is he doing he's put his mind to figuring out the train what about you same thing sort of i found some instructions but i can't read them okay we gotta go to the rv well i'm sure someone can help you duck duck's eyes are they're closing oh no i can't believe carcass is dead I can't believe this is this how people felt when Glenn died in the walking dead is this how nobody is safe goodness gracious actually yeah oh my god oh pencil pencil shut up in the tomb take take it dummy grab it there you go?
Okay, what about that banana drink?
Can I try that?
Oh, yeah.
Let me see the banana.
Banana.
Oh, I'm trapped.
Okay, there we go.
Glenn died?
OMG spoilers.
Sorry.
Use it.
Just eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Thank you for the super- Ah, Taco!
to see what I said, though.
I'm sorry.
Banana drink is a recurring joke in Telltale games.
Oh, is it?
That's fun.
Alright.
Perfect.
You can read it now?
Yeah.
Should be able to just follow the steps to get the engine on.
Sounds good.
Six, five, nine, nine.
Okay, I'm guessing that's like the the door I think we got this wait which door never mind I don't I have no idea wait
oh no wait back hold on some people are saying inside let me go see inside real quick oh there can I have a look oh here oh I see it I see it okay okay okay six how can I how do I see the thing wait should I have oh wait should I have taken like a screenshot or something wait Uh...
Uh...
Oh, oh, use notepad!
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Down, down.
Down, down, and this was like...
Oh.
Up, up.
Up.
And then...
Up, down, up.
Up.
Down.
Oh.
Son of a bitch.
Whatever you did, let the dash up.
Let's go.
So far so good.
Konamiko, yeah.
Alright, use notepad.
It was five.
Okay, so.
Horizontal vertical.
There we go.
Horizontal.
Now we're talking.
Okay, easy.
Alright, and then it was nine, nine.
Which, maybe, look it right at lunch.
Ew.
Maybe nine is out here.
Okay.
Um, it was like, there was one of these.
Was it this one?
Nine!
Okay.
Uh, one to the left, one to the right.
Left.
One to the right.
Yahoo!
Holy shit.
We're golden.
Yeah, we...
This thing is loud.
So what?
We're barreling down the tracks at 40 miles an hour.
I don't care about the noise.
I mean, but...
Let's fucking enjoy this.
We can't have too many zombies.
They'll clock it up.
Should I
follow you?
It's all yours.
Me?
I get to do the honors?
Look at throttle.
That's the throttle.
Does it work?
Ah, we do need the...
Okay.
We're still attached.
Yeah.
Can you go find out where we're stuck?
Get us stuck we gotta use the ranches or whatever the minkey ranch what does that do okay hold on let's go check it out see what because there was like an un something there was like a i can't remember what it was called is
it this one or is it this one no i think we need this cart no otherwise we
can't fit in the in the main compartment I don't know sorry my brain I can't tell though it's not right here I don't know where it wants me to look to the box car
can you go around I'm trying to oh okay oh maybe here over here
oh wait wait wait wait yeah I didn't go this area yet aha oh no oh yeah yeah yeah
there's gotta be a better way to do this okay okay
shit broken okay okay can i try it coupler pinch
wait did i get it oh oh gosh i didn't have to go back and get a new Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, I did have a tool.
I guess it was fine.
It didn't matter.
Yahoo!
You touch any of my stuff?
Oh.
Where'd you come from?
I took the map of the train routes.
That's fine.
You can have that.
Okay, thanks.
Yeah.
i got them all right up here i guess it's no worse for where i didn't i didn't tell him the truth charles if you're fancy leave you let your crew outside yeah and the guy up in the cab yeah he is him too i saw you walking through here and thought about scaring the pants off you what but i couldn't force myself to do it you're still kind of freaking me out train folk will do that already met everyone outside oh they all warmed to me right quick in direct oh okay i was gonna say dude why didn't anybody tell us i think there was a guy here hey chuck can we have your house don't mind the kid that's literally zombifying right now you met chuck it's so nice to meet someone normal for a change true he gave us candy ben too oh oh i was what about that
yourself selfish ben selfish ben joki's fried oh welcome sorry thank you you bet kid i didn't want to be mean that i didn't want to be mean and shares my love of the road that's for certain
i'm awful sorry your son's not feeling good i appreciate your concern well with a little tlc i'm sure he'll be there's a fiddle in no time and I can offer y'all whatever I got although it ain't much.
Some of those pills.
We could have given that to him.
Why don't we hold off on stay with us?
We'd like the company.
I think Chuck seems nice.
Charles, if I'm fancy, I'm feeling fancy.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
oh I did not mean they go so that's it we're cut loose seems that way yeah great we don't got much left so just gather whatever you have let's go wanna ride well it sounds like you're taking my home yes then anything better for keeping the creepy crawlies out than that box car yeah it's fair duck sick yeah on the train Clementine don't be mean to Clementine hey he's getting sicker let me look at him oh he's turning green real oh god uh I can't ignore this we can't ignore the kid kitty this is happening ain't shit happening and if it were what can we do here we get on the train and we find something better that is the plan I think Lee just wants to talk it through it's talked through Get home,
Kat.
I'll be up front.
I don't want to hear any nonsense until we get where we're going.
Maybe he's car-sick.
He's just feeling a little motion-sick.
That's why he's turning green.
Candy, don't be like this.
Okay, I'm going to full throttle.
Maybe he swallowed a beat.
He's allergic.
Oh, no!
Ah, nice and slow.
40 miles per hour.
This will definitely take care of anybody.
Any zombies.
Just talking about Outer Wilds with my friend earlier on.
I love Outer Wilds.
I love, love, love.
Oh my god, not the gaunt.
His face is all sunken in.
Ew, that guy is missing an arm.
I wish I could play Outer Wilds again for the first time.
That's me in the morning.
Three adults, taking care of three kids.
No disrespect, son.
Well, there were more of us.
Dead, get them.
Yeah, something like that.
Oh, well, yes?
Uh, yes.
Yes.
No, it's a shame.
Lee.
Lee, I need you right now.
I need you to go get Ken.
Would you get that off his face?
My hands are full here.
He's gonna bite me.
He's gonna bite me if I do that.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Could you just get that off his face, please?
Clean duck.
Oh my god.
He's out of time.
We need to stop this train.
Or you could just throw him off.
Oh, Clementine.
I'm going to go get Kitty.
Hold on tight in case the train stops fast.
I'll get this train stopped right quick.
Yeah, I am.
Stopping the train.
Stay put.
Okay.
Why is he so grumpy?
Is he so grumpy because...
Oh, I got to go the other way.
That's right.
because he's in having withdrawals maybe I think I do believe so that maybe someone is grumpy because they haven't been able to have their fix would you rather surprise bandits or zombies on your chain well if it's Halloween surprise zombies would be kind of fun you need to stop the train there's no stop in the try buddy you got to go say bye to your kid wait where's the where's the brakes where are the brakes oh show the rag what Ken what the hell's that your son's blood your son's blood get out of here Lee you know he's dying nobody knows shit he'll be fine wake up yeah wake up fuck up man this is over he's dead don't you tell me to wake up i got a real family i'm trying to protect not that sham you're running back there you apologize right now oh fight him yeah calm down and how the fuck do you calm down after a day like today
your friend yeah what is the god damn deal he's a little sick yeah we're not fighting it's a scratch he's not like the others jesus all y'all are just making it worse that's true he really is not like the others stop the train stop it god damn it fuck you you're gonna listen or what okay i think we're fighting i think we're fighting now come on fists fists knock this shit off you this is a second morning yeah this is yeah yeah I do I do I we're just talking just want to talk here relax we're talking talk Chan Chan thank you so much for the fight get the thank you uh wait you couldn't save Herschel's son then and you can't save duck now shut your mouth so you're running like a coward oh we're fighting yeah fight Oh,
I told Khajiit I'd get you to stop this and you bet your ass I'm gonna
Come on I've had your back.
Don't make me fucking regret it.
That's true.
That's very true Hey, man.
Come on.
You want to hurt people because you're afraid losing duck ain't enough for you because you're fucking lose everything acting like this I'll fucking kill you before I let that happen.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Please forgive me for choking you out.
I knocked some sense into Kenny.
We did it!
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry your son died.
27th birthday to JP release the Metal Gear Solid 1 Thank You Akira!
Yeah!
We don't...
Again, it's... I think it's time.
Oh, he doesn't sound very good.
Oh, Mr. Duck Detective.
The boy's been bit.
In case you haven't figured that out.
Oh, uh, what do you need?
What do you need?
I...
Gotcha.
It's time to...
This is not possible.
What are we gonna do?
Our little duck detective!
We can't allow him to become one of those things.
But what if... what if he doesn't?
Kenny, I love you very much.
I love our son more than life itself.
I need you to hear me.
What you are saying, that he may not turn, is foolish.
But...
No.
There's...
Come on, cat.
If you think of one, you let me know.
Isn't there some sort of pill or something we can just give him?
Stop it.
Just drift off to sleep, right, hun?
I mean, Jesus, this is our son.
I know, but we know it's here or nothing.
That's true, that's true.
Just who, then?
You want me to?
You don't have to.
I'll do it.
No.
You don't have to.
God, you're fucked.
I can.
I can do this.
I'll do it.
No, it should be apparent.
They will remember that.
You'll be able to do something like this.
Lee's right, Kat.
We can say our goodbyes and just let that be it.
I'll old yell at him.
Don't worry.
Lee, you'd be doing this family a great service.
Why don't we take him into the forest so Clementine doesn't have to see?
Yeah.
Give us a moment to say goodbye.
Of course.
Okay, but be fast because he's sound like he's about to start.
You know.
You would think that the train sounds would attract zombies, but maybe they're not out this far.
Except duck.
What's happening?
Oh.
Oh, Clem.
Duck is dying.
I think we should be honest with her.
I know.
But we don't need to tell her that we're the one handling it.
What are you doing?
Going to make sure he's okay.
In a sense.
I'm going to make sure he's okay.
Yeah.
But how?
He's bitten.
I'm making sure he doesn't come back.
Oh, she'll remember my honesty.
Look, Clem.
Things are...
What the?
No!
Finn, take Clementine into the train.
Go.
It'll be fine.
What?
Why did they take him out so far?
Oh, my gosh.
We're, like, really running in.
Gotcha!
Cat, cat, gotcha.
What?
Why?
Cat.
Oh, hi.
Oh, fucking God.
I don't even...
Oh, my God.
I...
Oh, Cat.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, we've lost so many people this chapter.
What the heck?
What do we do?
Oh.
Give me the gun, kid.
I'll do it.
Oh, Kenny.
Oh, why are they really making me do it?
It's no good.
I can't do it.
Oh, duck.
It's just like...
Oh gosh.
It's just like Metal Gear.
I'm gonna be doing this again in Delta!
No!
Duck Detective.
That was so bad.
That was actually just so bad.
this whole chapter you understand what happened yes oh okay what are you thinking about what chuck said what chucks say that what happened to duck would happen to me what the fuck he did swear sorry i'm gonna go talk some sense into it don't be mad why did he say that um excuse me hey hey how you doing um why did you say what you said to Clementine I don't care what reasons you had for doing it no reason to go and tell my girl she's gonna end up dead because she is I don't know much about you folks but I can tell you as sure as the Sun's gonna come up tomorrow but y'all keep going on like this and that girl ain't gonna make it what do you know I know that you don't have a goddamn plan we get to Savannah and then what I don't know uh we we do what's best for clementine best for clementine oh well then you do have it all chuck doesn't like that mind look sit down with the girl and hash it out find a map for christ's sake i'd give you one if i had it and if something were to happen oh but
you had a plan just chilling in the train if it were you gotta prepare the girl teach her to use a weapon and for crime and he cut that hair what's wrong with her hair She's a little girl.
She's a little girl.
And she'll die a little girl if you treat her like one.
Okay, that's better.
You gotta consider her a living person.
That's it.
You're either living or you're not.
You ain't little, you ain't a girl, you ain't a boy.
You ain't strong or smart.
You're alive.
Look at her hair.
You gotta run around with a mop that's gonna act like Velcro to any hand swinging its way.
Find some scissors in my pack and take care of that hair before Walker does it for you.
my god and then i know he has a good point but it makes me upset that's what saves your life from here on now he has a point but it makes me bad i don't mean to tell you how to do your job but too many people have died already that's so true they have yeah and seeing another little girl die might just do me in i hear you a plan a haircut and a gun it's good advice it is yeah push him off no you have any family Out there somewhere.
Been sort of on my own for the past little 14 years.
14 years.
Sorry to hear that.
No one to blame What yourself?
You're homeless, then?
Suppose I've had homes here and there and They just don't work out.
I like a drink, you know?
Yeah Got any?
No.
Darn.
Nope.
nope where are you headed uh that way i mean when we get to savannah got a few ideas we'll have a talk when we get there about whether or not you folks want company are we just gonna talk about we're just gonna talk about duck i guess okay i shot the kid you know i suppose someone had to
safe up here you bet you gosh we lost everybody of like we like everyone who had good character now we're stuck with ben boring ben oh kenny kenny are you okay hey man you and me we uh oh let's just get to the ocean We're on the bro route now.
You still want to get a boat?
It's still the best plan.
Yeah.
It's the best plan.
Carly.
I wonder if I get by you for a second, Kitty.
Can you just leave me alone?
I want to see the map, please.
Just a second.
Yeah.
Are there any maps in here?
Are there any maps up here?
I don't know.
I just want to look over one with Clem, so she has a lay of the land once we get to Savannah.
Wait, please.
Please, Kenny, please.
You mind if I'm looking there for a second?
I really wish you'd just leave me alone.
I just gotta reach over your shoulder.
Don't worry about it.
Get out of here.
Just one second.
What's your problem?
Kenny, Kenny, Kenny, just reach that for me, bro.
If I could buy you for a second, Kenny.
can you just leave me alone it loops back from him getting really mad to to not okay we'll just wait until he has to pee or something oh i bet hey ben hey hey aren't aren't many of us left aren't many of us left yeah you me and kenny clementine the homeless dude if he sticks around
Yeah, you're going to be able to step up?
Are you going to be able to step up?
I can do just as much as anyone else.
Okay.
Good.
I hope that's true.
Yeah.
I was thinking that.
I was just like, he hasn't done anything.
Like, this guy has been completely useless.
Carly didn't have to die, you know.
She would have killed me instead.
Carly?
Yeah, maybe.
See you.
I don't think Carly...
Yeah.
I don't think Carly would have killed you.
What are you talking about?
Oh my god.
He means Lily.
Oh, Lily, oh, I was just like, why are you talking?
Oh, he does have a bottle of whiskey.
Uh-oh.
I hope we're not on this train much longer.
That blood could come from anywhere.
Looks like Chuck has some booze left.
we're just gonna take that so he doesn't you know it's a fifth of whiskey oh wow that's a lot okay chucks camp he's lived here a while what oh what's he got scissors in chucks bag oh that's right we gotta cut her hair give it to kenny those are huge we're not gonna give the man who is driving the train oh you know what let's try it Alright,
I'll be right back, Clementine.
It's not like he's steering.
That's so true.
Oh, I can't.
It won't let me.
If you want to drink, let me ask.
About my past.
I wanted to talk to you about keeping my past from your...
You told us it was your parents' store back in Macon.
That was enough personal information.
I'm sure... Cat would be okay with you, so forget it.
Okay.
Oh.
I don't think we should give it to him.
We don't know what this guy is like drunk, but we can find out.
I found this if you wanted.
Damn.
Didn't realize I had it left.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Want a nip?
No.
No, I'm fine.
Suit yourself.
to be cutting Clem's hair yes anybody in there want to share a drink you let them know well too I don't know maybe you should be drinking on the hanging over the ledge of a of a trade either we're gonna get everybody killed Kenny you want to drink check wanted to know if you needed a drink he's got some yeah go crazy white girl wasted yeah that'd help oh now we can get them up noise okay oh thanks that was fast zero clock baby
i don't think we should give ben anything but i kind of want to hear hey ben hey hi oh ben is like a teenager Never mind I forgot then you can't drink it was me I was the one giving the bandits supplies.
He admits it
It's all my fault
Why I could kill you I could kill you I could hi Nobody could see us.
I could toss you over right now and be done with it.
No, I leave, please This guy's gonna push us.
They said they had my friend.
I didn't know what to do please please wait what do you mean their friend I had to tell someone I bet you did
let me add them
the disappointing just oh my god
our girl got shot because of you it really should have been him hey cliff did you talk to him I did he had some he explained himself and made some good points then I'm not gonna let anything bad happen to you killed like most of the people in our group because of his actions okay yeah that makes sense yeah he could have admitted it and saved Carly okay what should we do well we'll figure oh my god teach you how to protect yourself and uh tidy up a little so you can't get grabbed so easily yeah i like that ah be careful around ben be careful around ben i like ben no i know he's just young it doesn't make the best choices be careful i'm young you're smart just listen to be Ben is not smart.
Ben is not smart.
Oh, the good rest of your team.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
What a crappy day.
That's such an understatement.
You need to know how to protect yourself.
Like hiding or running away?
Got it.
I mean, with one of these.
Uh-oh.
First, look at her face.
She's like, uh-uh.
It's just a thing.
Take it, but know where your finger is all the time and don't put it on the trigger unless you want to hurt somebody Okay, okay Trigger discipline.
It's not scary.
It's a little scary.
You'll get stronger to aim you look right down the top through that notch Line up the sight at the end with your target Is there anything else I should know?
Aim for the head when you're ready to shoot make sure you're not breathing too hard and then hold your breath right when you pull the trigger like when i'm swimming no just for a quick second i found that if i did that it's a lot more accurate is the is the safety on i'm kind of i can do that okay
uh hold on i'm trying to blow my nose at the same time good don't lock your elbows okay let's take your first shot squeeze the trigger smoothly and i'll cover your ears nice and easy okay nice and easy oh you okay the hands hurt i don't like this let's stick with it okay do i have to yeah i'll be welcome to membership thank you don't lock your yeah keep it steady close now keep it steady aim higher okay a little higher day oh too high aim left okay aim a little bit more to the left aim lower aim lower oh too too much aim right to the right keep it steady steady now almost got it I got it excellent good shot good shot oh again
okay aim left a little bit more to the left and aim lower a little bit lower there you go nice okay clown again again fix your arms
i did it yeah you did good job good job i was holding my breath and the gun didn't shake so much not walkers though no far from it but you know how these things work now we'll graduate you to walkers one day okay i feel good that's so scary huh no oh gosh please be careful fast learner holy cow you taught clementine to protect yourself my hands hurt and my ears have noise in them like
Ah, what a crappy day.
What a crappy day.
She's pretty good.
Three months ago, I'd known what you'd be seeing.
I don't know if I would have taken you with me.
I probably would have run out of food.
You're damn near starved with me.
I'm glad I came with you.
What do you think about Chuck?
I don't know.
Me neither.
He might be an okay guy, though.
First rule of gun safety is have fun.
So true.
I want to talk about Savannah Me too And what we're going to do when we get there We don't know what to expect The city could be bad or totally under control I don't know The thing is You and I, we're a team, you know And a team needs a plan Aside from everyone else When this train stops You and I should know exactly what we're doing A plan I like it Not put in a cough drop Good Good Oh,
we should go our own way.
Uh, we should find a...
We need to help find a boat.
It's our best bet at safety.
Okay, but we'll be in Savannah, and my parents were in Savannah.
I know.
Look.
No, I don't care about safety.
I care about finding them.
We'll look for them.
Okay, we'll look for them.
We'll just... Really?
Yes, of course.
Clem!
I'm sorry.
Let's look at the map.
where they were we can start there okay let's oh looks like we'll come right through town if there's nothing on the tracks to hold us up she gonna see her zombified parents here I imagine and from there we got all the Savannah to the southwest of us now we've got a good chunk of Savannah here what do you think they always stay in the same place when they go there oh it's hmm hey don't worry we'll figure it out have you ever been there once well think about it tales on here but read this map and maybe it'll jog your memory yeah they've got really tasty desserts it's called the M something me are is this it the marsh house the marsh yes that's it oh there we go we'll head there yes yeah they'd be rotting zombies I think it's very good can I tell my parents you know sure sure go ahead why are we not gonna I know we're still treating her like a little girl but like wait what does she want to tell them actually now I think about what what does she want to tell them what hey clip hi that I'm
a murderer you're probably not gonna like this oh no what happened nothing we have to talk about someone it's not safe that's not nice what are you saying it smells no what cuz it does oh kind of oh oh do you remember when Andy st.
John grabbed it and I got mad yeah well that could happen again and if it's a walker well we need to trim it just trim the best haircut is some what's wrong with her eyes I think I thought...
I think she's a little broke.
I guess not.
Don't mow.
It's a good thing.
Oh, there she is.
Lift your head, Clem.
You can do it.
Her hair is way too heavy.
This is why we're cutting her.
Do you know how to do this?
Uh, how hard can it be?
Oh my god!
We just cut to this.
We just...
Oh, okay.
It's still there.
you did kill someone before yeah i'm glad you finally told me i thought it cut to the next scene and he chopped off everything it doesn't even matter that's true just joining team bald here we'll we'll go bald in solidarity killing is bad no matter what oh killing is bad no matter what yeah but you do it now to protect yourself and to protect me doesn't make it good but you have to I do it because it's necessary walkers aren't people yeah okay I think I'm about done I can probably tear these pieces back with some here I have some hair thingies you do hair thing yeah I also call them that for sleeping there everybody's dead oh my gosh
Does it look dumb?
Wait, he gave her pigtails, it's so cute!
Wait, I can also have twin tails.
It's so bright, sorry, sorry.
She looks so cute.
How do you feel?
Good.
Better.
I'm glad we have a plan.
And you're a good little chef.
Thanks.
I guess we should see how far.
Oh, shit!
Hold on, everybody!
Oh, my ears.
Charles is like, whatever.
Oh.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck!
Maybe we could walk.
That's fucking stupid, Ben.
I'm just saying.
Hmm, I don't know.
I ain't got much experience with y'all's fortitude, but we could probably deal with that.
Uh, or you?
We got a goddamn train.
A thing's not full of milk, Charles.
Yeah, exactly.
It's flammable.
It's gas or diesel.
Something that's going to explode.
You've got to get a hold of yourself.
This is a crew here.
Oh.
This ain't shit.
This.
Yo, you keep screaming like that and you're going to get your face chewed off.
Oh!
Are you guys going to be trouble?
Because we could have just kept walking.
Oh, oh, oh, define trouble.
Why is my thing?
Define trouble.
Anything that gets you killed or worse, and it tends to come hand in hand with groups of guys in distress.
Let's give these guys a break.
We'll see.
They'll remember that.
You guys got a problem with your train?
Yeah, you're standing right in front of it.
Dude, it's a wreck.
It's not so bad from up here.
Send your buddy up to have a look.
Hold up.
ways up there we won't let them escape okay I'm coming we'll be down here okay we're gonna get a good old beautiful view if I come up there you better not be murderers or thieves I guess you'll have to find out keeping me in suspense a group of guys is what we need they're what you think we We're doing fine for now.
What about when stop it when?
Hey, dude.
I'm Omid Lee.
Krista wants to deal with the train.
We're driving it.
Oh, man Uh, it's been a bad day.
Oh, yeah, I'm not gonna bullshit you our group is a little fucked right now He had a bite victim then his mom took her life and before that just it's okay.
Yeah, it's been a bad day.
Oh shit Oh What are you doing up here?
Do you know how long it's been since I've seen a kid?
Shit!
What's your name?
Why are you so excited?
Oh, so he gets to swear.
Oh, this is great!
See?
Things are looking up.
You're not her dad.
He down there?
It's that obvious?
To me.
And no, he's not down there.
Huh.
What's your story?
I don't understand why people think it's so weird that like a girl is traveling without a...
Yeah.
I came across Clementine alone.
First day all of this happened.
You know, like, everybody's so weird about it.
And everybody down there.
In this kind of situation, it just feels very like, um, Ben is young and stupid.
Ben's young and stupid, and I think harmless.
I know, no, no.
I did not say that!
I know, we just have to keep an eye on him.
No!
It's been rough for everybody down there.
I'm sure you can say the same.
We're sorry for anything that's happened.
to you guys that train is awesome though that tank is a real problem we'll help you with it but if we see anything we don't like we're moving on down the road alone we'd appreciate the help you can't just blast through it i guess if you could get it down the rest would probably be pretty easy did we forget that did we forget that four people are dead because of ben i cannot believe this
oh gosh okay well this seems really difficult i'm not gonna lie let's go talk to your people man oh me what he's so excited am i gonna have to tell your people the plan or what okay hold on i'm looking around gosh it's empty uh-oh there's somebody in there folks probably had their way Mostly harmless.
Oh, okay.
We got some tape.
Nice.
That's about the only useful thing in here.
Oh, gosh.
I didn't say that at all about Ben.
Oh, they put words into my mouth.
I think I've said it before, but like people are so like I understand that it's just like a girl without a girl a kid walking or kid going around without their parents is weird but like in this sort of situation it does not seem weird at all whatever government work was going on here didn't seem to help
like in fact it seems like oh you saved this kid I don't know an apocalypse you ever people are just finding everybody angle to hell no releasing it no nothing i don't know there's no way i'm pulling anything apart down there all right let's go talk to our friends guys this is oh meeting krista big on welcomes i told you we had a bad day yeah we just wanted to say hi and say your train it's pretty cool but we're not looking for charity we could help you guys though maybe it's time we move forward yes oh meet and Krista gonna help us we're gonna get past this damn tanker we're happy to stick around we'll see about that you want to start in on that tanker I'll get to know the girl for a minute if you don't mind yeah I'll show you how this thing works in case something happens oh really kid it's probably for the best oh someone might want to have a look inside of that station.
Show me how this works.
Sounds great.
Let's do this thing.
I'm Kenny.
I'm sad, Kenny.
Is he playing the guitar?
I'm glad someone's managed to keep this spirit.
Oh.
I'm the
Rumban.
All this power, we're still stuck.
Deserves to die.
what are you doing up there anyway do a flip he's actually so stupid got a clear view up there yeah we're good for a ways thank god no he's being lookout someone anyone to come along in and exterminate them or something us wait uh oh the the the walkers get used to them i don't think they're going anywhere anytime soon yeah well their numbers keep up and ours I'm telling you if they ever get a hold of me and I know I'm not getting out of it that's it man I'm just gonna punch my own ticket punch your own ticket yeah take myself out don't be dramatic and don't let them get a hold of that's right stupid
That's right.
I don't think there's anything else down there.
The flower.
Oh.
Always with the scenarios.
Oh, what a guy.
Wait.
Hi, Clementine.
So cute.
You interrogating this woman for us?
Yeah.
Yep.
Gee, set off any alarm bells?
Not yet.
She's very thorough.
Oh, good.
That's what I like to hear.
Yeah, they're having girls talk.
Oh, hey there.
That's a pretty useful radio for her to be holding on to, no?
It's busted, but it means something to her.
Oh, I understand.
Yeah.
Careful, she's a crackshot now.
You got this girl shooting guns?
Look, I don't need a lecture.
You weren't getting one.
It's good.
Yeah, should be able to take care of it.
Exactly, exactly.
She's cross-eyed.
Gosh.
She's high on the on the on the excitement.
She's like, yeah, I can shoot guns.
Oh my gosh.
Where are you from?
San Francisco.
Oh, geez, a long way from home.
I blame the one in there.
He wanted the great American route trip.
he got a little more than he bargained for huh who the hell is into civil war history anyway other than old white guys wonderful you two be thick as thieves
why was he
He looked so damn goofy about it.
Oh my god.
He's so funny.
Oh.
What are you guys arguing about when I was coming up the ladder?
Nothing.
If you're gonna be around for a while, Master Ballad and welcome back.
Thank you.
Then maybe we won't be around for a while.
Krista didn't appreciate you prying.
The zombie outbreak happened.
I hope I get to meet men.
I know whatever group she ends up will survive.
But also, I'm a ghost, so...
What do you think he's a professor of?
Was he a professor of history?
I can't remember.
Not sure how we'll get that tank down.
Maybe ask Omid.
He likes to break things.
Omid.
Okay.
I like the music.
Alright, we're gonna go check out the...
Maybe I should check out that train.
station yeah there's definitely gonna be some you over there you don't like the new girl I do but it's like we're a team like you said yeah all right too cute Clementine and I are checking out this train station all right hustle over if you hear anything hustle over I'm afraid though I think there's gonna be something in there oh
it's like oh survivors inside i don't know about that what does that say what does it say everton and schultz dobbinny finds silver
mac mac mac mac auto
ray brand auto parts Wait, why can't I look at that?
Like my mouse doesn't go down, that's weird.
Somebody was doing some painting.
Yeah, we see survivors inside.
Somebody was doing a lot of painting.
Somebody was doing some painting.
How did they get in though?
Gamer paint on the roof.
I can't read girl please you should wait for me before trying to open doors yes please sorry luckily it's locked we'll get better at working together okay one second actually guys I have to have to go use a little ghosties room so give me one moment I'm also gonna get some more water cuz I ran out I'm gonna get some water we're gonna take a little short break and then and by short break i mean very short so i'm just gonna pee and grab water okay here we go
i'm back sorry about that my cats in here okay sorry about that okay dokey all right also grabbed a cookie i got some uh pumpkin cookies
Paz!
Paz my baby girl.
She's my little baby girl.
Nah, she'll be okay.
But I'm not have to let her out.
Later on.
I got a fork.
I think that thing's worked in years.
Dang.
This place seems kind of busted.
Let's see.
I can't see in there.
Hmm.
Um, and it's locked?
What's Clementine got?
We'll have to find a way here.
Oh, hello.
Old Bert.
Okay.
Hmm.
I don't see another way.
Yeah, we could try knocking, right?
Like, if there's...
I can't I don't know why we need to look at all these signs It's making me nervous like do I have to remember them Uh okay there's nothing on this side
Well yeah I feel like if it says survivors inside why don't we try knocking right
Let's see Is this are these signs gonna be the test oh i see the window above the door the windows open up there maybe i could look in okay the windows open up there maybe i could look in why don't i put you on my shoulders and you can peek into that window up there sounds good
Thank you.
Okay, I can see in.
What do I do now?
Uh, what do you see?
What do you see?
Lots of crates and stuff.
Maybe we can find the key or figure out a way to knock this door down.
Kenny'd probably have me pick the lock, which actually might work now that we have the time.
I think I opened it.
For real?
I think so.
Well, I'll be damned.
Okay, Miss Clementine.
Wow.
Let's go.
Be careful.
I'm supposed to tell you that.
It just saved, so I'm scared.
I wouldn't let that door shut.
Damn, it's dark in here.
Maybe I can hold the door open?
I don't like that.
I'll prop it open with something.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
What's...
Why do we have a timer?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
We're fine.
There's gotta be something useful in here.
Shipping in...
There could be anything!
How are we doing?
Good.
What do we need?
Something to help us deal with the tanker out there.
Yeah, why was there a timer?
Something to help with what?
Why is it like a jail?
It's locked up good, but there's some space at the top.
Oh, no.
We're lucky.
I'm so little.
No!
Yeah, we are.
You know who else was little?
Oh, I called her small.
Oh, Carly.
Don't say duck.
I wasn't going to.
Wait, am I actually going to boost her?
There's some space up there, but not much.
We're lucky, I'm so little.
Yeah, we are.
Well, I guess come here.
We're going to boost you again, Clementine.
Oh, this is going to be bad.
You okay going over the top of this fence?
I think this is bad.
This is bad.
Yeah, definitely.
Huh?
Oh my god, it just saved.
Go on and grab the keys, Clem.
Come on, scoot.
Behind you!
Oh, gosh!
Fuck!
Where did they come from?
Oh my god, no, no, no.
Uh, get the thing.
I'm the walking dead.
Go on and grab the keys, Clem.
That was fast!
That was really bad.
Come on, scoot.
Behind you!
Where did they come from, though?
Also, survivors inside.
You guys are such bonies.
When did the zombies learn how to ride?
Get it, get it, get it!
Got
the QQQQ?
QQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQ-QQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQQ EngciaQQ.
Yeah,
they're learning.
Little big.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Keys, now!
Oh, my God.
Uh, please.
Open the door!
God damn.
so good no you did not so good no we're okay everything's okay oh my gosh what's going on i thought i heard a gunshot we're fine hey you know could have been better we found some walkers you and an eight-year-old versus three of them huh yeah we're so good
yeah that's pretty impressive we we handled it we handled it yeah it looks like what if you hadn't well then i get to start over i'm gonna go make sure the noise didn't cause us any problems that's a good idea cute
i hope you know what you're doing with her uh me too me too for her sake
Krista won't forget that she just had to stink eye us one last time before can we prop this open again I don't want to go outside I just want it to be light in here wait what's that okay never mind you sure you're okay audacity is like I know shaky it'll pass like what else do you want us to do you want me to do i don't get it they didn't have much business back then blowtorch we got it let's go outside now what did we learn i'm not ready for a gun we learned not to be afraid we learned not to be afraid they should have got us but we got them yeah you're right fear is the thing that will kill us you understand oh Aw,
I should like that.
Let's
go.
Fear is the mind killer.
It's true.
Is this guy's name again?
Odin?
I found a blowtorch in the station.
Should make quick work of the coupling up there.
Excellent.
I'll come up there with you to have a look.
This guy is way...
too excited about everything omid what did i just call him i can't i can't remember anybody's days i'm sorry
okay anyway we're just gonna use the blowtorch on the hitch oh dennis yeah we're just gonna call everybody doug from now on if doug if everybody is doug then doug never died what's The holes that's a leak in it.
I know!
Turn it off, dude.
I don't want my eyebrows burned off.
Better plug that leak with something.
Dog never dies!
Odin, the Allfather.
I don't know what I...
Uh...
Oh, I got the tape!
That's right.
This guy's eyes are bugging, though.
It kind of scares me.
Everybody's a dog.
That's crazy.
Look at it go.
Just about got it I'm scared
Whoa, thanks no sweat man.
This thing is hanging by a thread the smallest cut and it'll go Levi look at the membership there.
Thank you.
I'm all bad with names now.
I'm sorry Here the weak portion of the couplings out of my reach you think it'll be within mine No But I'm gonna dangle you over that ledge.
The hell you are.
Yeah.
God, you're a real son of a bitch, aren't you?
Shut up and start cutting.
Start cutting.
Guys!
There's something coming!
What the what?
There must be thousands.
We gotta go!
Fuck.
Omi, cut, cut!
I am!
It's going!
Pull me up!
Oh my
god.
Can he go?
Oh my god.
Let's blow her up, baby.
Holy crap.
Wait, maybe wait for the train to go.
We gotta jump.
What?
No way.
Yes way.
We gotta.
Um.
Oh wait.
Jump!
Jump, damn it!
With his eyes.
Come on!
Okay.
Oh.
Shit.
He's fine.
Get him up.
Yep, there you go.
No!
Wait, she can keep running!
You piece of shit?
She's a woman, don't you know...
What are you talking about?
She's fine!
It's okay, honey.
I'm okay.
You were the one lip-pick you wouldn't have made it!
She seems really fit, yeah.
I think she's fine.
She's a woman.
What was that supposed to mean?
The fuck?
That was a lot, Bill.
Are you hurt?
No, we're okay.
Speak for yourself.
My leg is fucked.
That's your fault.
You didn't stick the landing.
Fine.
so excited anymore i like how some of the zombies are frozen like they're all not moving some of them are just like little pngs
they just give up yeah
is that kenny
i wasn't gonna push him i'm not i'm not his mom
No, I saw him.
I saw a little quack, quack.
I saw him.
Oh, it's all three of them.
Oh, he can't see this.
It'll break his little heart.
It'll break his Kenny heart.
We trust the ladies are more independent than men on this train.
The lady?
Well, there's just one.
We will.
It was a real sausage fest here for a moment.
You'll be all right.
I'll be alive, I guess.
The tried and true advice.
You'll get over it.
I'll leave you to your thoughts.
She's out cold like I've never seen.
Oh?
No way.
Can't wait for you to get to Savannah, Clementine.
I got your parents right here.
And you be sure to find me whether Lee wants you to or not.
Now, what do I need?
Holy shit.
Lee?
Wait, what?
I thought that fucking thing was broken.
So did I.
Well, sounds like somebody knows where we're headed.
Who the fuck?
How?
What?
I don't know.
But I doubt we're going to be happy when we find out.
What?
How do they know?
Oh, my God.
She's like the president or something.
Clementine is the president.
She's a secret princess.
Wait, what?
We're almost at the river.
You want to get on a boat?
You want to wait around till the walkers figure out we're here?
We need to focus on finding the boat right now, Cloud.
Like we talked about on the train.
No, we talked about finding her parents at the...
I don't know how much longer he can keep on like this.
If his leg gets any worse, we're going to have to carry him.
Or leave him.
Doug.
If I were you, I'd get...
out of the street now who the hell is this answer me damn it this is crazy what is this mystery who have you been talking to oh you come back here i'll kill you you understand i will kill you
let's see you and 59 of players did not shoot the girl on the streets my gosh so much has happened this episode?
I completely forgot about her.
You and 42% of players left Lily.
I mean, come on.
55% of people fought Kenny.
I did fight that guy.
A lot of people.
Almost everybody shot Duck.
79% of people shot Duck.
Clearly been at the end.
And then you and 55% of players helped
at me for it my gosh he wouldn't have made it he would have died only 42 percent of people left lily they're crazy they're crazy but i'm i feel like i'm playing pretty in the middle so far so like uh i think i think uh usually i have like one thing that is an overwhelming majority that most
Hey baby girl.
Come here.
Come here baby girl.
What are you doing laying on the ground?
Are you so cute?
Are you the cutest girl in the world?
Are you the cutest girl ever?
The littlest, tiniest baby girl.
Are you my little baby baby?
Pies.
Look at me.
She's not even looking at me.
She hates me.
My cat hates me.
Ah!
Oh well.
But yeah, oh my gosh.
What an episode that was.
That was a long road ahead.
That was actually insane.
We lost so many people.
Duck.
Lily.
Carly.
Katya.
Like, wow.
Wow, we lost our home?
That's crazy.
That was really intense episode.
Oh, you and 7% of players left hanging.
I didn't know it was time.
And I was in mid-sentence being like, should we leave him hanging?
And then it said, You left duck hanging.
The last time when Carly died and things just got worse and worse.
What a ride.
My gosh.
Carly, I did not expect at all.
I don't know why.
I thought she would have some semblance of, like, love interest plot armor, but that's just not.
I should know.
That's not a thing in The Walking Dead.
Literally nobody has plot armor.
I think I'm most upset about Duck in a way because I feel like I was really fast.
I feel like I was pretty fast and I shot that thing.
And I'm upset about it.
The game wants Lee X Kenny.
Lee on Kennedy.
It's foretold!
It's already written!
Leon Kennedy!
She cracked the code!
Only Daryl has plot armor.
That's Norman Redis, right?
This episode is so rough, mostly thanks to Ben, though.
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you, Timaru!
How did they get out of it?
Yeah.
Ben.
I can't believe he...
You know, he could have just said something before...
Before...
Uh...
What's her name?
What even got the gun out?
Uh...
Lily.
Leon, Kenny, D's nuts, got him!
That made me bald.
he was correctly afraid of being kicked out well no we kicked out we kicked out lily because she killed a person um we could have just you know we could have done we could have thought of something to do with him i don't know but i do know guys as i am show hungry I'm going to go eat dinner.
So thank you so much for more Walking Dead.
I guess we have two more chapters left, right?
Because it's five chapters.
And, yep, yep, yep.
What am I eating?
I got me some chicken Alfredo with my name on it.
Thank you, everybody, for hanging out with me again.
Thanks for watching.
Thanks so much.
I will see you when I see you next.
Have a good day.
Have a good time, Joan.
And I will see you later.
Otsobito!
Ita-tara-shai!
Bye-bye.